[Music]
hello everyone
my name is elisa i am a member of the
mba admissions team here at stanford at
the stanford gsb i'm joined
by three panelists and we hope to have a
fourth joining um during this time
and we're excited to have you here today
to talk about preparing for a career in
education
and impact how things are gonna go today
is we have about 55 minutes together i'm
going to give you a brief introduction
to the stanford gsb to our global
community
i will introduce you to our panelists i
have some questions for them to start
our conversation
uh today but you also have a chance
in the q a pod as uh we start speaking
or if there's something particular that
you would like answered today um feel
free to ask
questions um along the way and i will do
my best to moderate and make sure your
questions get answered
so again i want to thank all of the
panelists for joining us today
and all of you also this is a really
great turnout we're excited to have all
of you
so as i said i wanted to talk a little
bit about the global community here at
the gsb
um specifically because this is a
career-focused discussion and piano
today about preparing for a career in
education and impact we wanted to share
the information we have on that in the
sense that 91 percent of students
had job offers from the gsb three months
post graduation
with over 445 organizations
i'm hiring our stanford mbas for
opportunities these could be full-time
or summer opportunities
a really interesting thing and perhaps
this is relevant to some of you on the
call today
71 of students made a pivot that means
they were in a certain industry before
coming to the gsb and ended up doing
something else after
possibly due to something they were
exposed to or learned about um while at
the gsb so our panelists can share a
little bit more about their career paths
as we get to that
um because today specifically around
impact and education
um an interesting stat here is that 19
of those who graduated are in socially
responsible roles
18 started new ventures including some
of our panelists here
um and then of those new ventures 12
percent actually turned out to be in
healthcare most recently
for more information on career paths and
even just to learn about our career
management center i encourage you all to
visit
our our webpage you know you can search
for gsb
cmc which is one of the acronyms for
career management center and one of the
many acronyms here at the gsb if you
want to learn more
um but again hopefully that's just a
teaser for you thinking about your
career
thinking about where the gsb might help
you or lead you
on your journey we are joined today by
four wonderful panelists i'm excited to
have all of them here
um rather than me introduce each of them
i'm gonna have them introduce themselves
so um if each of you can you know
introduce yourself
talk about what you were doing before
the gsb and
and what you're doing now um after or
perhaps what you've
done after and might be doing now
because you may have done more than one
thing already after
um please do so but i'd also like to
queue up with our first question of
in addition to introducing yourself
please share with us
perhaps what was your most impactful
experience or memory from the gsb so
this could be a course you took
an extracurricular activity um a travel
experience whatever it may be
um just what is kind of most memorable
or impactful to you
during your time here um we'll just go
in order um
so starting with anuja hi everyone
welcome
so my name is anuja burns and i
graduated um
2010 as you can see so i've done
a bunch of things so um you know i went
to mit for my undergrad
i did engineering internships and post
mit
i went i worked at bcg i was doing
consulting and private equity
but i knew i wanted to change so when i
went to stanford
my goal was to find a job that i loved
and post stanford i ended up
helping run an internet startup and then
i started a preschool
so i started a preschool in 2012
and that was so fortunate because i sold
it right before coven early last year to
bright horizons
which is a huge public company and now
i'm
running a non-profit and we're working
on education in
india i'm also a casa where i work with
foster youth and
just doing a lot of volunteer work and
um
to answer the question eliza so for me i
would say
the way stanford has impacted me is the
community so there's
people who just who take the time to get
to know you
they care and they push your thinking so
when i was at
at stanford i was thinking like you know
i want this job i love
but i was on a very ambitious path prior
to business school
and so i was still in that mindset and
so they had this opportunity to get a
prestigious fellowship where
i would be placed at the top of a school
district and you know you help implement
change in a school
from you know above and i talked to my
friend john
he was in the joint degree program with
me the
education mba joint degree program and i
was like john i'm so excited
they have this broad residency this is
perfect for me
and he was like anuja you're crazy
that's just consulting in a school
district
like you like working with kids that's
what makes you happy like why are you
going back into consulting
and i was like huh you're right and you
know just that one
conversation it helped me think about
what i really wanted to do and then i
you know did a business plan to start a
school and you know i did start a school
so i just think that community of people
who
push your thinking is you know very
unique to stanford
great thank you christina could you
introduce yourself
and also um share your most memorable
experience
from the gsb sure
hi everybody it is great to be here and
as you can see i'm the class of 2019 i
went to amherst college for undergrad
and i studied psychology
and right after graduating from college
in 2013
i taught with teach for america in baton
rouge louisiana
i was a 6th and 7th grade math teacher
and after that i decided to go into
consulting um
i you know kind of was trying to make a
pivot from from education
and try to kind of like hone my my
business skills a little bit
so i decided to go into consulting and
then from there went to the gsb
thought that i would go into education
consulting afterward or nonprofit
consulting
but i decided um to pursue
um the social innovation fellowship
which i'm sure we'll talk about
today because claire is also a fellow
but i received funding to launch my own
venture hope bound which i'm currently
working on
and we are an adolescent mental health
nonprofit
so we partner with middle schools and
high schools and connect them with
essentially free weekly therapy for the
kids so we
focus on schools who don't have a budget
for
a school-based mental health
professional on the campus and i've been
doing that for
two years which has been great so far
and let's see my favorite um or one of
my most impactful experiences
it is hard to think about but the first
thing that came to mind was probably the
class touchy feely
um which i'm sure a lot of you all have
heard of but
for me i think i still think back to it
really often just think about a lot of
the
things i learned about myself as a
person and i actually still
meet every month with what's called the
support group so it's
um two people from your touchy feely
group um that you
meet with over the the retreat weekend
but anyway it's been about two years as
i said and we still meet monthly so
clearly it's had an impact
on me so i felt like that was a really
valuable experience
great thank you for sharing claire um
thanks for joining if you could also
introduce yourself
um and share with us your most memorable
or impactful experience from the gsb
that'd be great
yeah i'm claire thanks for having me um
i did my undergrad at stanford and then
also taught in louisiana um
like christina i was in new orleans
taught high school math and did
um and was an administrator at a school
public charter high school there um and
had like really believed in schools as a
unit of change
um like a lot of other panelists here
it's it's
really exciting to hear kind of how
everybody's gotten into the space
and i had also just found that we were
graduating kids and they were dropping
off
after high school so the you know
college persistence and the workforce
connectedness issues felt very real and
so i wanted to
zoom out understand different school
models and do the joint degree program
to kind of better understand what was
going on
outside of k-12 and in higher ed and in
workforce development to sort of
re-evaluate
where the kind of where my place of
leverage might be
to ensure that our young people are in
more stable lives in their mid-twenties
um and so through the same program that
christina referenced um i founded a
non-profit that
is a national it's a national
organization that strengthens the school
to work pipeline so we have
a set of resources and advisory support
directly for young people
in and around high school and then we
have an institutional support practice
where we help school districts build out
extension programs to help plug some of
the gaps where
students fall through the cracks and one
of the
there are a lot of really influential
moments
i actually think the the sif the social
innovation fund application process
um was really meaningful i hadn't really
had formal training
before with you know making slide decks
or pitches or trying to kind of
really clearly articulate pain points
and
all the different kind of components of
articulating where there's a need and
where
i might support and so it felt like the
one-on-one support that i got through
that process was really rigorous and
really personalized and
i don't know that i'd been pushed to be
as good of a writer in
school in the past so it felt like a
pocket of
many different pockets like that exist
at school where
kind of if you take initiative there's a
ton of support
great thanks for sharing that um
danielle if you could introduce yourself
and share your most
memorable or impactful experience that'd
be great and you are a recent grad so
you should have that top of mind
hopefully
yes thank you very much for the
invitation i am danielle i'm from
colombia i just graduated from the
nba master education joint degree a
month ago um
before the gsb i did investment banking
two years
in europe and mexico and then i joined a
higher education financing
startup back in colombia and then
i founded a non-profit which is a career
development mentorship program
that we help low income college students
decide what they want to do with their
with their lives with stanford design
your life my biology and they help them
get the best jobs
and i did that um two years full time
before coming to the jews
and i was a university professor as a
professor
and for me the gsb wasn't just an
incredible experience and
just want to highlight that the
uniqueness of the joint degree it's an
incredible program
not only because it gives you a lot of
flexibility on
how you want to choose your your
electives from the ed school
and basically literally there's only one
required class and there is elective so
you
you um tailor it towards your interest
mine is education entrepreneurship and
investing
and also from the impact fund was an
incredible experience i was part of the
education team
um and then learning just from from all
the teams around impact investing and
very fortunate because we could invest
in a columbia net tech startup actually
so it was a cool experience um and then
the the other highly will be the article
fellows program
i think it's i think the most unique
program at the dsp
it's a incredible leadership development
program and just
an intense uh self-awareness
introspection process
throughout the entire year of the
program and i highly highly suggest
everyone to to do it to apply it makes
you i think makes you a better person
better manager better leader um
definitely uh i think will be the thing
that
that i will cherish animals from from
the experience apart from that so the
community which is
incredible but that program was very
important
great thanks for sharing daniel i
actually just since you answered about
that i do want to clarify for everyone
on could you share a little bit more
about the arbuckle
fellows and just what their role is um
especially how it
how they mentor the first years and just
what what that role is like
sure so so basically the first year the
first
there's a classical leadership labs
where basically we have a squad of six
mba ones and they are led by an mba
tools and arbuckle fellow
basically this as an mba too you're
trained
uh it's it's a methodology called
co-active coaching it's a coaching
methodology
through coaching through inquiry and
curiosity and basically
we we have that we do our first year we
apply to the program
around 70 are selected six for
for six mba once per per fellow and then
we get this very intense training
where we first facilitate this class
as a fellow of the nba ones and then we
become
coaches to three nba ones in our third
quarter
fifth quarter i think fourth and third
quarter and
basically it's an intense uh one-on-one
coaching five or six coaching sessions
with
three different mba ones different than
the ones from the first class
so it's a it's an intense coaching
program that we go through
great thanks for explaining that just
because i have a feeling most of the
people on
have have probably not heard of the
arbuckle fellow um fellows before
um so one of the questions we have uh is
around the
joint degree which i think many of you
did i know
um anuja and claire mentioned it i know
daniel did it christina
did you do no okay so let's um
focus this question then to anuja and
claire if you guys could
um speak to uh just how
um how did that your decision process go
in terms of deciding to do the joint
degree
and did it help with your career goals
career aspirations
specifically um so anuja why don't we
start with you
yeah sure so it had a huge impact on my
career because
through the joint degree program is i
did um
i think an independent study with an
education professor
and that's where i did my business plan
to start my school so
it was in one of those classes we had an
education class we had a guest speaker
and we did a case study on
a woman who started a middle school in
mountain view and
um i talked to her and she said i said i
want to start my own school this sounds
so cool and she said
oh we'll do a business plan like work it
out and going through that process it'll
really
help you and then you can just start one
and i was like okay
so that's what i did and because the gsb
and the ed school are so flexible you do
have that opportunity to
sort of create the curriculum you want
and um
looking back at my business plan i made
i had a timeline in it and i think in my
timeline i said
i would open doors september 2012 of my
school and i ended up starting it
october 2012 so it was sort of cool that
i was able to
you know bring this plan to life great
thanks
i'm claire do you want to share just how
you decided to do
the joint degree and how did it help you
in your career
yeah um i was pretty involved in
education in undergrad at stanford so i
i didn't feel
like i felt like i had some exposure to
professors already
but i i came in sort of feeling like so
you can
you can apply at the outset or you can
start your mba and then apply and i
had applied at the very beginning um
i think first and foremost it was just a
like really intentional decision that
i wanted to pursue education as a career
and
the gsb can pull you in a lot of
different directions and i felt like the
commitment to the ed school and to the
group that was in the joint degree
program was
a really helpful anchor for me um
i felt like i made really good friends
who are
we still continue to meet in a small
group to kind of we're all in
you know summer and investing some are
working in
product and just kind of all over the
map in education but
a really helpful um
set of kind of professional friendships
i would say that continue to serve me
and it was it was just a helpful
informal space when i was there too to
be able to kind of
like a new jo's talking about kind of
lean on different professors lean on
students and be able to explore
different things with the sort of added
lens
of education and i had previously
studied
education with more of a teaching lens
and this felt more of like an
organizational lens with a couple
different pathways which
was just sort of coming into the
business school with this idea that i
maybe wanted to
think about building a business and
managing
people it was just a helpful layer um
that was more kind of industry specific
great thanks for sharing that um
christine i want to
gear the next question towards you um to
start with answering and again any of
the panels feel free to chime in but
we have a question um around just how
does the gsp support you
um if you are starting something in
social impact so
um if you you know have an idea but
maybe not
a budget and you mentioned already uh
the fellowship
that you uh received and were part of so
if you could share
um just about that but also in any other
ways that the gsb may have helped you
on your journey towards starting
something specifically in social impact
yeah definitely so um just to share a
little bit more about the social
innovation fellowship
so um each year there are two people
that are awarded the fellowship
um and they um
as of last year it was only for people
launching non-profits
but now is for people who are just
launching social ventures in general so
they could be
for-profit or non-profit um
can everyone hear me yeah i just
realized it might have frozen
okay for a second i thought i thought it
froze because like the three faces i saw
really
so so they were listening intently to me
i guess um
but so um i won't go too much into that
right now
i know that the link was sent out in the
chat and because it is only two people
each year
i think it might serve serve me better
to share more about the other options as
well so for that fellowship
however um they do um
provide you a hundred and ten thousand
dollars and a year of advising to launch
it so it's a really wonderful
opportunity
um but some of the other opportunities
that could take place is one over the
summer so if you want to test out
some of your ideas to launch your own
social impact venture or if you want to
join one that already exists there's
funding that the cmc
the career management center as well as
the
the center that's over social innovation
entrepreneurship provides for you to
not be concerned about the value that
you're paid over the summer
so they will essentially um like double
your salary so that it's on par
with what your other classmates
classmates would be making
in a more traditional internship so
that's really um
just unique and i think it shows how
intentional the gsb is about trying to
remove any
financial barriers to go into social
impact
another example beyond the internships
and beyond the fellowship
is the loan forgiveness program so if
you
decide to enter into a social impact
career
and if you are making below a certain
cutoff and i won't quote any specific
numbers because it might have changed
but your loans could be forgiven so
that's just an um you know a third
example of how the gsb really does take
the um budget part of it that was
mentioned the question
into account great thanks for sharing um
that's really helpful i think for those
on the call
to hear that uh and just to chime in a
little bit about loan forgiveness i
also i'm not gonna say an exact number
just because that always can
change but i encourage you if you want
to learn about that program it is
something
that is offered so were you to come to
the gsb and take on loans and then go
work
in a non-profit or in the public sector
um you could be eligible then for this
loan forgiveness program which again is
one of the ways uh the gsb is committed
to
helping those pursue careers
in this area so um i do want to
jump there was a question and they're
all i'm kind of changing but there was
one
specifically around clubs or
extracurriculars that may have
helped kind of shape you or exposed you
to
certain ideas or people or things
throughout so if you um
could speak to and we'll start with
daniel um
you know what clubs or extracurriculars
you may have been involved in that also
kind of helped you on your path towards
social impact or education
i think as i mentioned i think arbuckle
fellows
impact fund and joint degree like those
three things are it's a big commitment
already
and then the other ones um
education club is a nice social thing to
basically meet people from the gsb
internet education
and from the ed school that are also
i think they can join and basically a
newsletter of
of things of things related job
opportunities
and just information on it on education
and then everything related to the
to the social innovation center uh
especially the having having a good
relationship
and and with yeah like an advisor that
you can like for me was not me buyer for
example
and just having regular catches with her
uh
just to you know tell her the things i
was doing she always tried to you know
connect me with people that were
relevant send me
stuff that was relevant to my interests
and
at the end more than yeah like i think
joining a club is is good because
there's that
you'll see who are people interested in
the team
um that you're but at the end it's gonna
be like literally you can do many things
outside of a club and just
literally do independent independent
projects for working outside part time
or you know doing an internship or doing
a special party with any institution
you're interested
for example i with the impact fund i met
the advisor of the impact fund is all
ventures which is a the largest set of
pc fund
and the advice education team they're
mostly gsv years
um and just getting to know them through
the impact fund i then say i want to
work with you guys
to help you open like invest in latin
america
that was one of the most important
experiences for me and i got credit for
that
and i just got an incredible relation
with them and learned a lot from them
so i think just knowing that while
you're a student
a and gsb gse or
android gse credential are just huge so
the amount of opportunities that come to
you that you can do on the side
are are literally unique so i would
highly encourage
everyone to be creative and think okay
what what am i interested in
what institutions are the people i want
to reach out and why am i unique
for like in my in my theme and and just
tell a good story to
get and create the opportunity that you
want based on your interest
great thanks claire could you chime in
and share um maybe a club or
extracurricular that
um influenced you or helped you during
your time at the gsb
yeah um i actually didn't formally join
a lot of clubs i sort of
didn't want to be spread too thin and so
i focused a lot on
taking a lot of classes across
the gsb and the school of education
i went to a lot of office hours like
sort of
got a good read really these are sort of
like informal things to get involved in
but
got a good read quickly on kind of which
professors were really invested in
student growth and um and then i did a
few different independent studies and
internships as kind of mini
tests to like answer a couple questions
for myself about my career so like did i
want to
start my own school did i want to start
a school from within
a network what were different models how
could i
do projects with those types of
institutions to really get to know them
with professors that would help me
kind of pull apart some different themes
and and then i spent a lot of time
getting to know my classmates um and
trying to trying to carve out time
to sort of like learn more about their
background i sort of
only knew teaching and working in
schools and
learned a ton from other people's
experiences in terms of how to build or
not build culture across different
industries
just sort of things like that from
informal conversations
and i found the summer internship
program through smith
um that christina i think referenced
really really useful because that also
created
that was a subsidized nonprofit
internship i worked for a venture
philanthropy fund that supported schools
so it was a better
chance for me to kind of understand
thirty thousand foot view did that feel
engaging and meaningful to me um and
was part of a kind of network of
classmates who had also participated in
that program so that felt like a good
way to sort of
pressure test some things and have some
folks to be able to reflect with
but i think sort of throughout it was
either formal or informal ways to just
have conversations with people and use
the opportunity to
be more self-reflective that i didn't
feel like i had when i was
you know working and and more kind of
focused
on on my job great um thanks
christina could you share if there was
um
i guess you know an experience whether
it's extracurricular club related
um that also helped you along the way
and
if it's been already mentioned you can
say that too
yeah i mean i think honestly i would say
i'm i am like claire where i was
i don't know if it came from like being
burnt out as a teacher in the past but i
just like really
wanted to conserve my energy and be
intentional so i didn't
um really join any clubs um the one
the one extra clue in which i was really
involved was the bbsa so the black
business student association so there's
you know tons of different affinity
groups and i was able to
help lead the revival of the annual
conference when i was there
so i think that was a really great
you know experience in just leadership
public speaking
dealing with logistics and operations
which has served me well now
running my own business um but i would
say
the one other thing i will make a note
of it was a class but it's called social
ventures practicum so it's kind of like
startup garage which you all may have
heard of
but it's focused on social ventures in
particular
and i actually was able to recruit six
different students from all across the
stanford campus undergrad
different grad programs to help work on
my idea for hope bound and that was my
first
time really being able to like manage
people um
it was a you know quite quite an
interesting experience
learned a lot of things um so that i
could be a lot better at it now
but they just want to know that but i
would say no other specific clubs as
related to social impact
um christine i have a question was the
social venture practicum
one quarter or was that over multiple
quarters
yeah it was over one quarter um
and it was taught by um two professors
one bill meehan um who has more of like
a uh consulting background and then
another one kim yonker
um or kim starkey um
now and um she's focused more on like
philanthropy
so it was a really interesting
combination of the two
great thanks for sharing um we have a
question and that's been kind of
upvoted to um you know what is it that
caught you most off guard when you
started business school so what has
surprised you most about
uh the gsb and i you can feel free to
answer that um
i'll probably start with daniel since
you're the most recent uh
graduate of the program but i also want
to for many of you
of our panelists so for many of you it's
um it was a
change uh in terms of coming to business
school from what you were doing before
and there is another question so
feel free to kind of what surprised you
but also in your first year
um maybe share what that adjustment was
like so in addition to your surprise you
know what
helped you adjust um to being in
business school
especially if you were pivoting from a
different industry
so again we'll start with daniel sure
so i think the intensity of the first
couple quarters
everything it's a lot a lot of
a lot of a lot of things uh basically
um yeah there's a lot of incredible
unique opportunity you think that every
every coffee chat every bbl like
events in the in the afternoons every
speaker they're all
they're like oh this is like probably
one of the most unique experiences i've
ever had to meet this person or hear
this person at all
so if you any of you are are
intellectually
curious and like different things
it will be it will be it'll be a muscle
of practicing when you really
understand okay what am i here for and
what am i going to spend my limited time
and that involves like you know personal
stuff friends
classes bbls and
working on independent projects so
that's that's the
the first thing then the first year
classes
are are very depends on the level and
the level of experience each person
comes with but
but they could be um more
um the more traditional the one that
when you think
and and again it's kind of a core
curriculum things that you gotta
go through and a good for me i
i started kind of working part time
since second quarter probably
and basically it was really good that
at the end the grades at the gsb are
don't matter that much if you want to do
great you can
go and try to be an arbuckle fellow
sorry an rj miller which is a top 10
percent
but if you just want to pass you can
only pass i think that's
that's one of the one of the
misconceptions maybe that it's
very hard the class are hard and yeah to
get your grades and you got to study and
do a bunch of stuff
but if you just want to pass and focus
on certain classes
or in others maybe don't focus much and
just do the birmingham because you want
to
put your time to non-academic stuff you
can't do it
and that gives you a lot of freedom that
come and i think
that makes the community be much
stronger and the people wanting to
all help each other i never felt any
type of competitiveness in terms of
my classmates in a class just helping
each other and i think that
that's great and that's
yeah yeah after the first quarter
because first of all you got to get your
first classes and make sure that you you
pass and you're in an accounting
probation
but after the first quarter i never felt
kind of a lot of stress in terms of
academics
i think that's that's a huge thing for
the program
hey thanks for sharing um i'd love for
each of the panelists to
to answer this just what had surprised
you most and then maybe of
any tips or or learnings from your first
year so anuja why don't we go
um around at least how i see you guys
yeah um i would echo a lot of what
daniel said but for me i do remember
thinking um
it was quite rigorous it was much busier
than i was expecting because
i don't know if people still say it but
people would say oh business school it's
sort of a vacation or it's fun
or something you know a lot of people
come when you're coming from finance and
working these 80 hour weeks i thought
cool i'm burnt out i need a break but it
was still incredibly busy
but in a much different way in a much
more engaging way a fun way and
there's classes and there's parties and
clubs and
just everything travel experiences and
my classmates they're like hey it's
tuesday let's go to vegas for the night
come back on wednesday i don't know if
it's still the same
but balancing all of that and getting
over this
fomo right the fear of missing out and
learning how to really
focus your efforts on the people you
want to spend time with and the classes
you want to spend time with and the
trips and
just because everyone's going to the
world cup doesn't mean you have to go
like you know and so
i think that was like not overwhelming
but maybe
and then once you figure it out you have
your core group you learn more about who
you are and then
i think those are the friendships and
relationships you take with you
when you leave the gsb
uh christina could you share
yeah i feel like i could just say ditto
to all that
honestly um yeah i think for me
i was really taken aback by just how
busy it was i
i remember it was the first time that i
was really
glued to my calendar um and it's like
kind of funny thinking back to it but
like daniel was talking about the coffee
chats and all that but
even the social things are on your
calendar like everyone just sends a
calendar invite for everything
and i wasn't used to that um before so
it was the kind of thing where it was
like all right it's monday at 10 a.m
let me check my calendar to remind
myself what am i doing you know at 1 pm
today
like um it so it was very very busy but
in a good way you know
very exciting um so many different
unique opportunities
but it kind of felt like
constant um activity so i think the
first year i kind of did let myself like
claire mentioned you get pulled a lot of
different directions i let myself get
pulled a lot of different directions
the second year i was able to be more
intentional and figure out what i wanted
to say yes to
um so that's what i would say kind of
you know echoing the same theme that's
been shared so far
great and claire could you also chime in
if there's anything else to add in terms
of
what surprised you and any tips in your
first year that you learned
yeah um probably two big things one
um i had a really hard time
with the fact that it felt like i had
gone from this place where everything i
did was so other people could be
successful
to being like only worried about myself
and grad school is just like very
self-indulgent and that's wonderful and
i think i just it took me a little while
to
name that and feel okay about it um
and i think once i sort of was like this
is just a different time in your life
and you're
here to learn so that you can be more
useful to people in the future
um that was the sort of helpful mindset
shift for me
um but i think because of what these
folks have said around just being so
busy it's easy to sort of
be distracted and not not give yourself
enough time to
pay attention to kind of how you're
feeling about the transition um
and then the second thing is that i
found the core classes really hard
and i was acutely aware of what good
teaching looked like and i was sort of
like
lectures are really hard for me to learn
in and i don't know that
i'm absorbing all the sort of financial
literacy that i came here to learn
and a lot of folks in the class know a
lot more than i do
and so i felt a little bit insecure
actually in the beginning
and and i think over time
started to feel like okay this is part
of a larger experience i'm learning
these things they're new to me that's
okay and
also some of the other people management
things and eq things that maybe i have
more exposure to
in managing other adults or classrooms
or things like that
um are gonna be relevant at some point
and so i think it was just sort of being
okay with
um you know being challenged and
feeling like um
i i think if if i were to
give some advice around that it's just
sort of like trusting the process
and sort of feeling like even if you
don't feel
really confident in the moment that your
strengths will play out in different
ways across the
two years or three or however long you
spend earning your degree
great thanks for sharing um we have a
question around global experiences
and specifically whether any of you did
pursue or fulfill your global experience
requirement with a focus
on social impact or education which i
don't know but i'd love for you
and some of you to share about that so
christina could you share
um what you did to fulfill your global
experience requirement and
actually before you answer just for
everyone on the call
um because this was a question some of
you might be wondering what is the
global experience requirement
which you can google and find more out
more you can find
about more information online but
briefly
there's a requirement for those who come
to the gsb to spend time in a country
they've never lived in or worked in
before and this can be fulfilled in
many different ways from a global study
trip
to another acronym called a gmix which
is a one month internship
so i'm gonna just throw that out there
just to clarify for those on the call
who maybe didn't know what that is
um so christina if you could share what
how did you fulfill your global
experience requirement that'd be great
so i went to greece um which was amazing
uh when during the springtime and you
know i think
uh reason who knows there might be
someone on here from there but
at least to me i just thought of it as
you know okay this beautiful tourist
destination
but um what we focus on what we learned
about was how the debt crisis had
impacted the inequity in health care for
uh grief people so it was extremely
eye-opening and i would say it was
related to
you know i ultimately decided that
accessibility when it comes to mental
health
was really important to me and that's
something i didn't see in the students
that i work with every day
as a teacher um so i think it does open
opened my eyes to basically
um how you know when there is a debt
crisis how tourism
tries to kind of offset some of those
impacts but who really ends up getting
um
you know impacted the most are the
people who live there and that
healthcare as challenging as it can be
in the united states
is definitely not something to be taken
for granted
at all so yeah it was a very interesting
experience
great um could any of the other
panelists i can pick anybody anyone want
to share about their political
experience
i think you're mine so i went to
thailand and cambodia
and we were focused on human trafficking
so it was pretty intense and
part of the global study trip we were
actually passing out
condoms in the red light district in
thailand and
um was able to talk to sex workers and
just really understand
all the societal factors and everything
that went into
um you know these people's lives and it
was really interesting and i was
part of a club at the gsb we were
focused on human trafficking
and ways we can help and so super
interesting and
you know i think what has stuck with me
is just meeting people who were
similarly passionate and who cared and
having these
you know conversations was incredible
great thanks um daniel could you share
maybe what
how things changed for global
experiences specifically
um you know travel was impacted in the
past year with kovid so
could you share how um you fulfilled a
global experience requirement
i was very lucky because i did mine in
december of my first year so i went to
brazil and did a
a entrepreneurship a study trip
but then i did my summer i was going to
go to brazil to work for a
private k-12 network and then to
colombia to work for a non-profit
charter school
and had to do both virtually so i did
smith
a social management innovation
fellowship i think
and basically it's a stipend that they
gave me
i think thirteen hundred dollars a week
for ten weeks and
later they paid me for me to work with
these two organizations
i was i stayed on something during
coverage stayed
in palo alto and and worked virtually
from there
i got a lot of maybe half of my class
fulfilled a pre-code fulfill their their
study trip and then the others did uh
virtual experiences
uh like yeah like i think like two
three-day
virtual sessions with some of the
speakers that were gonna be in the
country or speak in the country where
they were gonna go
but i i would say like from hopefully
everyone
can all travel in in the next year
or the next few years but i think the
global study troops are just an
incredible experience because they're
very well run not only the logistically
but the quality of the speakers is just
incredible and
the mba tools lead mb2s lead the study
trips
and they put a lot of work into it and
most of the people have deleted either
they're from that country or very
interested in their country
and then the gsb admin just facilitates
a lot of the alumni
uh networks to get the best speakers
just like like the best of the best
speakers
and experiences in that in those trips
and you have a lot of fun
there's some partying involved and
everything so it's it's very
it's it's just a great combination of
these are like
30 student trips so like you
you you create a great bond with the
people that go to the trips great thanks
for sharing claire could you share how
you fulfilled your global experience
requirement
yeah um i went to singapore in indonesia
and our um
trip was focused on ride sharing
and ride hilling and the growth of the
gig economy
and so fairly different from
a different sort of maybe education
focused initiatives
and i actually in reflecting on
different classes that i found most
valuable at school
some of them were just like completely
different from anything that i had known
previously and i think actually exposure
to stuff
in the for-profit sector and in
different
pockets was just
like really helped me push my thinking
um and kind of one of the reasons i went
to school in the first place is because
i didn't know what i didn't know
um and so i actually think you know we
met a
looking back it's sort of crazy the um
the sort of people and things that
you're exposed to
people in different places of power in
government talked a ton about
um how politics influences different
business decisions in
indonesia where there are different sort
of pockets of corruption and just sort
of thinking about
like i was also thinking about the
politics of education reform and just
different ways that that they had
approached
challenges felt like a useful kind of
new lens
great thanks for sharing um there is one
question and i think daniel you were
involved in this you mentioned the
social impact fund
um if you could just share a little bit
more about what that is and how
as a student you can get involved in
that um is it a course
or did you is it more treated like a
club if you could um just share a little
bit about the social impact fund
sure so so it's a club that you have to
apply
i think it's last year was uh
i think it's me there's like
seven groups within the fund education
healthcare fintech etc there's seven
groups and she has between six
and seven students who are mostly first
years
um each group is led by an mba too
basically uh i think last year the
acceptance rate
was like thirty percent or twenty
percent like a lot of people apply it
it's just it's basically a
just an incredible investing experience
like the most similar thing to
to we see um so so you apply in
november december of your first year and
you have to enter with your team leader
the each team leader creates their own
group and they basically go through the
entire experience of sourcing companies
in your
field and so you talk with with impact
fund with funds that invest in your
education so you go with all the
education pcs to for them to send you
deals
and basically you define a theme within
the group
you internally you talk with the
founders
and then you decide which ones you want
invest and then you vote internally as a
group
and then the top two startups these are
early stages are
seed and seriously startups that are
raising
funds and then um the top two startups
of every group you take them to an
investment committee investment
companies is composed by
some faculty members and just
sorry and just uh like like very
experienced
investors in in namepac investing
community
and and then you pitch those
to to impact to that to investment
committee
and then everyone votes both the
investment committee members and the
other team members
so that good things that you go through
the entire process even if you're
if you're a deal or the company you're
pitching you if
they don't pass you see the entire thing
the entire process of everyone pitching
and the back and forth of of of
questions between the
industrial committee members and the and
the
the people from the fund
um and at the end the company the fund
chooses between two and four
two and four startups every year uh that
and they get a 50 000
investment more or less and actually a
lot of people
that do that and then they can't have
that the experience to them get a job in
impact invest
or in venture capital so i think it's
the best way for those that want to get
into an investing role
it's just the most incredible way to do
it and then get a summer job
at a fund and then hopefully get a
full-time offer post
great thanks for sharing more about that
um we have five minutes left
together i want to pose one more
question to all four panelists
um which is asked by uh someone in the
audience named brandon who just said
what do you wish you did while the gsb
do you have any regrets
so is there anything you um
i don't know wish you had done more of
or just had more time to do
because i know time is always the
biggest um commodity
here but i'd love for each of you to
just quickly
um go around and share whether there is
something you wish you had done more of
while you were here so nisha why don't
we start with you
yeah i think well um after hearing
daniel talk so glowingly about the
arbuckle
fellows like man i wish i did that
because um
i just felt like i was so busy with the
joint degree program
but coaching and sort of that reflection
and
all these sorts of skills i think are so
valuable and there are things that i'm
learning
now that have helped me immensely in my
personal life and at work and so
if i was able to learn more of those
leadership skills and that
sort of the coaching model at the gsb i
think that would have been
cool great christina
yeah so i would say if there are any
other introverts out there
i actually do regret not socializing
enough
um i wish i could have found a way to
make it feel like more sustainable for
me i think i
i'm not the kind of person that would go
out on a tuesday night
um but i know there were other people
like me too
so i think like i definitely you know
have
a handful of really good friends but i
think there are more people
that were different than me that i've
gotten to know better
so i wish i would have gotten out of my
comfort zone a little bit um on the
social front
for sure claire
um there are a couple classes called
like
for example startup garage that help
train you in this sort of framework
for understanding uh
understanding pain points and developing
um yeah maybe
i can send some info to the chat um
going through the sort of product design
process for need finding um and i think
i at sort of different junctures
in evolving our business i have wished
that i had a better understanding of
doing ux research and really
precisely following a process where we
are
understanding what the need is and where
there are opportunities for us to
support
and so i would encourage even if you
don't
think you want to pursue
entrepreneurship there are some really
really high quality classes
around like lean launchpad as well
around just kind of what you need to
start a business or how you start to
understand pain points
that seem to be really relevant now and
i sort of wish i had taken more
advantage of them then
great and daniel i know you just
completed your disagree but
anything that you already wish you
uh had done while you were in school
yeah like of course the last year was
was crazy but
the unfortunate thing about about for
covet is that we
it was just more difficult to to meet
more people especially the people that i
didn't got close to in the first year so
it was difficult
our class is 420 people and then the
class below up below and above like it's
there's a lot of people to meet a lot of
incredible people and
and and yeah for me the regret is kind
of staying
with with the kind of the group the
groups or the people that i met in the
first year
um so i would encourage everyone just to
try to reach out as much as you know as
much as possible
whatever time you want to put into that
but just every person is incredibly
special and
they get into the gsb there's something
really unique about them
and for me what i always thought was i
wanna i wanna i wanna
meet that person and try to understand
what makes that person unique because
the nation saw something special in that
person
uh and and every time you the more you
meet you're like
amazed with the quality of the people
that come to this place
thank you so much for sharing i want to
thank all four of you for joining us
today this was an amazing panel
and i know i learned a lot i hope that
everyone who attended learned a lot
i'm sharing my screen one more time just
to encourage everyone who's on
to continue your journey at
mystanford.mba
where you can learn more about clubs
courses you can start to track your
application if you are applying
our deadlines for the next year are
already posted
and i also encourage you if you're
joining us today to look at our list of
events
for more panels if you're interested in
specifically admissions information we
have
information sessions offered throughout
the
summer also so again i wanted to thank
all the panelists for joining us
i want to thank all of you wherever you
may be in the world
again for joining us for this session we
appreciate your time and hope to see you
again soon
thank you everyone